Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
What's one interview question you ask every prospective employee?
So, I often ask questions
for people to describe an experience they've had before.
But when I'm interviewing,
I'm also recruiting.
So, if you're interviewing for a job,
realize that the person interviewing you
is also at the same time trying to
show how great their job is.
And so there are cues where you can acknowledge that
or show that you're listening,
show that you appreciate that.
So, in addition to trying to just answer questions,
I think picking up on that dynamic
can give someone a competitive advantage in an interview.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.